con nuestra primera invitada al día
vamos a hablar de los esfuerzos de
organizaciones y las selecciones
femeninas de diversos deportes por
alcanzar la paridad con los hombres en
temas como salarios visibilidad entre
otros es que este mes de julio fue un
mes de relevancia para todo el deporte
femenino con varios torneos en disputa
la copa américa femenina que se juega en
colombia la euro por ejemplo en
inglaterra y el tour de francia todos
con récord de audiencia y un excelente
desempeño de las femeninas nos acompaña
por supuesto en este estudio marc es a
nuestra periodista deportivo mar
bienvenida a esta mesa de trabajo y
también un mar leamos la bienvenida a
nuestro hábitat de ella es maria viloria
abogada especializada en derecho del
deporte maría muy buen día gracias por
estar con nosotros esta mañana de
directo américa
hola muy buenos días a todos ustedes
muchas gracias por la invitación es un
mar empezamos entonces de una vez
nuestra conversación
mariah para empezar quería preguntarle
por digamos ss ritornelo es
permanente excusa de que el deporte
femenino no puede o las mujeres en el
deporte no pueden ganar tanto como los
hombres porque no generan tantas
ganancias uno podría pensar que termina
siendo una especie de profecía
autocumplida porque los esfuerzos de
mercadeo y visibilización se hacen en el
masculino
partiendo de que venden más es este
razonamiento correcto
bueno yo creo que podríamos estar
debatiendo una hora el mar es una
interesante pregunta y la que yo creo
que principalmente siempre se hacen los
que nos siguen en el deporte femenino yo
creo que hay muchas cosas que tener en
cuenta primero el deporte femenino ha
tenido en grandes periodos de tiempo en
donde no se ha podido desarrollar a la
parte masculino a qué me refiero con
esto quiero dar el ejemplo de inglaterra
donde el fútbol femenino estuvo 50 años
prohibido variado por la federación como
tal entonces aquí vemos un retroceso muy
importante el primer mundial de fútbol
masculino fue en
1930 mientras que se empinó fue en el 90
estamos hablando de diferencias de 60
años entonces hay que tener esos números
muy claros para referirse sobre la
igualdad de condiciones y el marketing
ahora el punto que tú me dices claro
alguien que quiere invertir en el arte
se puede decir mira el fútbol el deporte
masculino en general me va a dar una
ganancia instantánea podrían decir pero
el femenino ha dado números muy
interesantes lo decía raúl hace unos
minutos estamos en un mes muy importante
para el deporte femenina en general se
jugó la eurocopa bien este fin de semana
al final lo mismo la copa américa
continente el tour de francia por
primera vez en una categoría femenina y
tienen números exorbitantes solo por
darles un dato
el partido que se disputó entre alemán y
francia tuvo nada más que 12 puntos 2
millones de personas a través de
streaming viendo el partido es decir un
47.2 por ciento del rating de televisión
en alemania entonces estamos hablando de
números impresionantes y claro cuando
hablamos de igualdad tanto de
condiciones como de pagos depende mucho
de cómo las federaciones de cada deporte
luego lo van a evaluar y bueno no me
quiero adelantar mucho aquí solo que me
pregunten ustedes pero es básicamente
son todas estas condiciones las que se
tienen que evaluar cuando se va
a debatir si realmente el deporte
femenino es o no rentable en comparación
con el masculino ahora maría también
estaba diciendo pues que hay una brecha
digamos temporal del desarrollo de todas
estas selecciones femeninas en
diferentes deportes le pregunto
teniendo en cuenta esta diferencia no
esta desigualdad cuántos podría digamos
a tardar para poder alcanzar digamos esa
paridad con el deporte masculino
teniendo en cuenta que como bien lo
decías muchos deportes incluso hasta
estuvieron prohibidos en varios países
oye mira esta brecha yo la veo muy
complicada de decirte algún número
aproximado de años o algo por el estilo
pero yo creo que el fútbol o el deporte
femenino en general ha evolucionado y ha
dado pasos muy importantes y esto viene
de la mano de las oportunidades que se
le den y es lo que siempre las personas
que al menos defendemos el deporte
femenino es lo que pedimos que se le dé
una igualdad de condiciones y se le
permita a las atletas deportistas en
general que puedan desarrollar
profesionalmente la actividad si ellos
no tienen esa oportunidad los campos de
entrenamiento los vuelos en estas
condiciones mínimas para desarrollar su
deporte como tal lamentablemente no
vamos a verlas nunca comparadas con el
masculino y otras aristas muy
importantes antes que el deporte
femenino no debe ser comparado con
masculino al 100% es porque nunca van a
ser iguales son dos espectáculos
totalmente distintos y es también un
engaño y algo de mala costumbre que el
deporte femenino llega a ser lo que es
masculino porque es como te digo son dos
prácticas totalmente distintas el
femenino va a llegar a su techo como el
masculino lo va a llegar a ser pero en
cada uno en su propio nicho entonces lo
que hay que enfocarse es que los
deportistas tengan las mejores
condiciones para desarrollar su deporte
y que todas se pueden dedicar el 100% a
esto y no sea un hobby sino realmente un
deporte profesional usted hablaba de las
diferencias y obviamente hay una
diferencia sustancial en el hecho de que
las mujeres podemos ser madres y tenemos
derecho a las licencias de maternidad
recordamos el caso de allyson felix la
corredora estadounidense cuyo contrato
con su anterior patrocinante fue
reducido en 75 por ciento una vez que
ella quedó embarazada este es otro de
los desafíos del deporte femenino
entender las diferencias
sí por supuesto se abrió lógicamente
estamos hablando de las diferencias muy
grandes incluso cuando estaba preparando
un poco esta presentación leí mucho hay
un tema de mucha importancia del
embarazo en la menstruación las
diferencias biológica que nosotros
tenemos con respecto a la fragilidad
para ciertas lesiones que se ven menos
en el deporte masculino como por ejemplo
las lesiones de la rodilla del ligamento
cruzado en el fútbol como tal son más
comunes en el femenino entonces van a
requerir de un sistema de investigación
distinto porque estamos hablando de dos
cuerpos biológicamente totalmente
opuestos y distintos entonces esto es
muy importante lo que tú comentabas del
embarazo vamos que las mujeres embarazas
desde el principio de la historia y se
ha venido regulando legalmente hablando
de hacer muy pocos años para atrás fifa
tiene una nueva un nuevo programa de
embarazo en el fútbol pero es muy
reciente igual se agrada ese que este
pero hace cinco años no teníamos ningún
tipo de formación y las deportistas
grandes vinculadas de sus clubes
terminaron sus contratos de patrocinio
como lo comentas tú por la sencilla
razón natural de quedar embarazadas
claro maría también digamos que hablamos
de esa paridad en torno a las
oportunidades que deberían tener pues
también estas atletas a femeninas pero
también le quería preguntar por qué
tanta crítica porque al mejor tanto
rechazo por parte de la población hacia
estos deportes femeninos lo
conversábamos en la reacción umar esta
mañana también hay mucha crítica a las a
las ciclistas del tour de francia porque
se cayeron entonces diciendo que pues no
eran tan buenas que se cayeron en una
recta porque porque vemos a su marido
mira la verdad yo pienso que esos
comentarios son super lamentable es raúl
y te comento por qué porque un accidente
en un deporte lo pueden tener en
cualquier disciplina deportiva y lo
pueden tener tanto hombres como mujeres
yo lo particular sigo más que todo el
fútbol femenino yo creo que es muy obvio
por lo que he dicho pero veo muchas
comparativas de cuando una portera
cualquiera no alcanza un chut en
arquería que la quería debería ser más
pequeña que el campo de fútbol debería
ser más pequeño por las condiciones
físicas de la mujer y yo no estoy de
acuerdo con eso porque también vemos
esas oportunidades o esos desafortunados
normales suerte en el deporte masculino
esto es algo de no no es que falta más
preparación no es que faltó algún tipo
de impedimento no para nada esto es algo
natural que puede pasar los accidentes
pasan ojalá nunca pasarán pero en el
deporte hay también riesgo porque
estamos hablando de deporte de alto
contacto donde se fuerzan físicamente
hablando entonces es algo que puede
ocurrir
lo que falta amaría digamos lo agrego yo
es respeto en la sociedad y también
puedes estar pues a la altura digamos de
estos eventos deportivos como lo están
las atletas femeninas que ponen todo su
empeño para poderse ser las mejores y
poder ir desarrollando estas disciplinas
mariah omar gracias por estar entonces
en esta sección hablando del deporte
femenino y pues de todo lo que conlleva
en un mes además muy bueno para las
atletas femeninas con la eurocopa con la
copa américa y también el tour en
francia y pues todo lo que hemos visto
en estas últimas semanas gracias maría
nuevamente por estar con nosotros